this is you you're on your third week of
class at Hillsdale and it's all amazing
professors are blowing your mind you're
making friends in your dorm and you've
figured out the shortest route from your
dorm to your first class but then
tragedy strikes one morning you roll out
of bed with a low grade fever you're not
sure but you might be mildly
hallucinating you have a few options you
could a slam a shot of nyquil and hide
in your room B go to class and start a
school-wide flu epidemic or C go to the
health center located on Hillsdale
Street right next to broad lines this is
Linda's nose she checks you in and makes
sure you're comfortable and taken care
of and this is Carol Drew's she can help
you tame that low-grade fever and get
you back on your feet
better yet she can give you a flu shot
so you don't get sick in the first place
and even if you don't have the flu the
Health Center can help you in other ways
meet Brock glutes director of health and
wellness and Katelyn zellner one of
several professional counselors they can
listen whenever you need help and
guidance now if you go back to your room
stay out of class get plenty of sleep
and drink a lot of water the next
morning you feel good you look good and
you're ready to get back to class